big news day today President Trump is
getting ready to sign his first major
piece of legislation a sweeping overhaul
of the tax system the Senate approved
the historic legislation overnight 51 to
48 the house must now take one more step
before sending it to the president the
bill dramatically reshapes the tax code
cutting taxes for corporations and most
individuals on Twitter the president
called it the biggest in history tax cut
and reform bill he plans a news
conference at one o'clock Eastern Time
the bill received zero support from
Democrats who say it does not provide
enough help to average American Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy good
morning good morning congressional
Republicans have been dreaming of this
day for more than a decade a 40% cut to
the corporate tax rate across-the-board
cuts to individual rates and now the
bill will have to go back one more time
to the house but this is essentially a
formality after both the House and the
Senate passed it yesterday the tax cuts
and Jobs Act is passed Senate
Republicans pushed their tax plan
through in the wee hours of the morning
after eight straight years of slow
growth and underperformance America is
ready to take off analysts project the
bill will cut taxes at every income
level next year on average taxpayers
will see a savings of $1,600 you're
gonna owe less money to Uncle Sam so
you're gonna get a take-home pay raise
it's as simple as that Senate Democrats
argued it's not that simple
it's government for sale by 2027 every
income bracket under 75,000 will see a
tax increase by the end of the decade
this legislation will provide 83% of the
benefits to the top 1%
House Democrats issued the same warning
is this bill about helping people who
are living paycheck to paycheck
hello but House Republicans also
prevailed and the minority of
fear-mongering what you're hearing on
the other side is complete false and
absolute lies the American public has to
be pretty confused by
they've got one side saying that this is
going to be a huge gift to every
taxpayer and the other side saying it's
a disaster well they're not confused
look at every poll two-to-one they don't
they don't like the bill Republicans
insist
public sentiment will change when the
economy continues to improve and way to
start increasing because we're full
employment Americans will realize this
is a good good move the American economy
tax cuts are such a big GOP priority
that congressional Republicans were able
to pull this across the finish line
without any Democratic support but now
they have to pass a government spending
bill by Friday to prevent a government
shutdown and there they probably will
need to compromise Norah with Democrats
Nancy thank you